giovani vediamo di far bene
avete capito dove siamo digli di andare
dall'altra parte
buonasera
[Musica]
sì vinto con il tanto passo campi hanno
detto tutto se non c'è trippa il gatto
mangerà se l'occasione una chimera
attenderemo quando è sera la metà cesa
ci dirà dove kussa le strade contorte
piene di buche sarebbe meglio una palude
macchina detto che continua spiagge
affollate caldes costiere da barriera e
porta ad avere il punto quello paga chi
perderà oltre poviglio sulla strada e la
lumaca resta in attesa
vuol sapere se si sposterà c'è una
corsia per gareggiare non siano venga a
farci del male se te ne sarai coniglio
protestare o che già la banda del paese
le soubrette con le pretese di baciare
la gara vincerà ma la jolie migliaia
al bar deve decidere che fa appiccicosa
e la banca dalla cia parte a razzo la
rubata ma io che mi frega tanto insicuro
che la gara vincerà poi all'arrivo
brutta sorpresa
cambia la regola decisa vince la gara di
ultimo sarà donne al contrario tutti i
giorni noi le facciamo solo nei sogni ma
nelle favole normalità ora il codino è
andato al bar perché c'è un conto da
pagare e le soubrette alla lumaca da
baciarmi sei distinto cod intatto passo
carpiato deco tuttora c'e trippa il gala
domanderà sui l'occasione mattiniera
attenderemo quando è sera la luce accesa
ci dirà dove bravi bravi bravi
[Applauso]
immagino che non sapete che cos'è questo
strumento che avete sentito suonare è lo
immagino si soltanto se per dire il nome
ti danno la terza media
ve lo dico che lo dico che lo dico si
chiama organo di barberia per musica
meccanica 27 note tutte le combinazioni
che volete in fatto di musica
funzionamento a olio di gomito olio di
gomito ragazzi ne faccio delle boccette
tutte le volte che vado a lavorare
il mattino dopo tipo stamattina sono
andato giù al mercato via l'ho venduta
ho dato la bottiglietta che aveva fatto
insomma nei giorni precedenti la signora
la presa zac zac che dopo aperto
laboccetta perbene glu glu le signore
che stavano di fianco cioè io sto
dicendo queste cose ma voi sapete come
si usa l'olio di gomito
l'olio di gomito si mette una goccia di
qua una goccia di là si strofina per
bene e da lì in poi la vita ti cambia da
così a così beh io appunto visto che
questa fortuna riesco a essere un
produttore sano di questo incredibile
prodotto che rallegra la vita di tutti i
giorni di tutte le persone che lo
conoscono
ma ritorniamo un po a noi lo strumento
costruito verso la fine del settecento
da un italiano il cui nome era giovanni
barbieri giovanni barbieri beh insomma
un esempio di fuga dei cervelli
all'estero portò lo strumento in francia
è lì che i francesi decisero che era uno
strumento barbaro il nome già come dire
convertiva bene con quello che doveva
essere poi dopo il seguito perché era
difficile coordinare il movimento dello
strumento con i buchi che dettavano
appunto le note riuscite a vedere sì
avete idea faccio vedere signori ogni
buco è una nota più lungo il buco più
lunga la nota più corto il buco più la
nota sara
corta corta beh vediamo un po prima di
fare il cd di spiegazione per quelli che
sono sotto il metro e barattolo via
il cd è inutile che vi sto a chiedere lo
conoscete al cd no
ecco prima di fare il cd facevano questa
roba qui il pezzo inizia qui e finisce
qui ma guarda te dentro osservate
signori secondo voi visto che siete così
anche algoritmo messo così tra i chiaro
allo scuro quanti buchi ci sono in un
cartone come questo qua sparate un po
sentiamo come nodi più di più no ve lo
dico non ve lo dico
ci sono più di duemila buchi per metro
rigorosamente fatti a macchina a
macchina ma ragazzi ma abbiate pazienza
ma avete presente che che lavoro
sì forse i primi vennero fatti appunto a
picchiando picchiando picchiano
bisognava andare i diritti bisognava
essere precisi ed essendo appunto la
musica un problema di matematica
qualcuno decise che era arrivato il
momento probabilmente di non suonare il
brano così dal vivo ma di farlo suonare
una macchina e questo è uno degli esempi
incredibili esiste questo strumento non
esistono ancora di più articolati bene
la cosa che è come dire che però mi
viene da fare adesso per deliziarvi
ancora per qualche minuto sarebbe il
fatto di chiedere a qualcuno di voi se
vuole provare l'ebrezza di suonare lo
strumento c'è qualcuno vengono più sul
davanti vediamo un po
uno è grave grati un po di luce in sala
grazie buongiorno si delirio signori un
applauso bye bye prego prego abbiamo qua
i nostri potenti mezzi della tecnica
anche perché io son dotato soltanto di
due mani e posso fare quello che posso
fare e come ti chiami giacomo giacomo
grande uomo
vieni allora senti giacomo dal momento
che ci siamo devo darti qualche piccola
indicazione anche perché per provare
un'emozione così insomma una piccola
istruzione ci vuole via allora io
produco il cartone nel suo lettore
giovanni guardate che qui cambia mano è
adesso a si è sì è vero non lo sapete
l'organetto funziona olio di gomito ogni
buco corrisponde capito però sta di
fatto che vedete qua ci sono 27 canne a
ogni canna corrisponde un topo che
all'interno dell'organetto con la canna
in bocca si mette lì quando lo mando
avere la gira ogni tanto ne becco
qualcuno che posso di soffiare aspira
con la via in altra storia verrà posso
raccontare poi più avanti insomma adesso
non ci credete
cosa sostiene i soli di così mi avete
topi nelle vostre case
no non sapete cosa vi perdete non sapete
cosa vi perdete ci vuole collaborazione
su quelle piccole cose che penso ad
esempio mi sto facendo aiutare da lui e
insieme farebbe una cosa eccezionale
siamo pronti allora senti adesso
inserito il cartone o più è chiuso mano
alla mano della corpo al centro mano
appoggiata sulla sinistra ad esempio
giovani ve l'avevo detto che doveva
essere differente guarda hai capito
va sempre a finire così scusate abbiate
pazienza bisogna essi si sentiva plado
che vedete è allora ricominciamo daccapo
messo qua la mano uguali corto qua
quando inizierà a girare
e normale che inizierà a vedere i buchi
capire voi non potete capire perché
siamo io e lui qua sopra e l'emozione è
tutta un'altra cosa diceva anti verrà
spontaneo a un certo punto alzare gli
occhi quando alzerà gli occhi il
pubblico davanti
inizia a fare
ok no no no tu continua a guardare loro
sorrisi perché poi dopo sempre in
mondovisione quindi un bel un bel così
sorridi noè il sorrisino per dove però
non perdere la concentrazione
capita allora vediamo un pochino a che
punto siamo
mano qui l'altra mano lily cole pace non
ballare che non nel caso poi si mettono
a ballare pure loro
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no grazie è stato veramente
d'altronde la collaborazione umana come
dire al suo lavoro non è stato
bravissimo no grazie bene e con questo
signori miei
vi saluto e vi rimando al fatto di
poterci incontrare ancora per le strade
e le piazze in giro per il mondo sarà
una stretta di mano e un altro piacere
d'aver incontrato ciao
[Applauso]